how much were you salivating at the  opportunity of a fight with nate diaz  i'm down that's a massive [ __ ] fight  him in the octagon in the ufc for free  of course eddie hearn he's a snake he's  like oh you're average eddie what if i  called your wife average you know what  i'm saying like that just want to punch  him in the face sometimes is there ever  a chance we get to see ksi and you in  the ring he clearly doesn't want to do  it my manager gets on the phone with his  and they never want to fight i think he  knows he's going to lose mike tyson goes  yeah maybe we can do a fight you think  you [ __ ] up mike tyson i would win you  would win  the biggest money fight out there for  you is you and logan logan and i like to  make history and douche it differently  and i think for that reason the fight  one day will happen  he would be the one that would have to  deal with that for the rest of his life